we have a system that more resembles a
dinosaur in too many ways which is a
small brain a huge animal and
inefficient system and one that doesn't
recognize its receive the deathblow on
one end of the body because the brain is
not equipped for it and that's what I
see and where we are now I don't believe
in just the two-party system
I want a multi-party system not too many
like in Israel where 60000 people can
literally change the makeup of your
country right you can have it absurdly
surrett amount yeah but over the years
from Ron Paul who I think failed the
libertarians massively because he didn't
build an infrastructure I've said to
libertarians build your state parties
find a few key states build an
infrastructure because in politics you
need an infrastructure and grow your
party so they can have a debate you can
have a real third party a viable third
party right but they don't do that work
they just go for the presidency every
four years and then it's just you know
and if you go for the marketing and you
don't build a good product you know what
you have failure yeah and it's worse
than failure in a way because it's then
you look more ridiculous each time yes I
mean when you get the outliers that come
out and they they're so ridiculous and
people go why would I want to be a part
of that crazy but to you as a Republican
do you fear that okay so let's say
they're libertarians a lot of
libertarians watch this show obviously
most of my political leanings are
libertarian wouldn't you fear that what
that does then is all right now we get a
libertarian party that's at 10 percent
it just took 8 percent of that from the
Republicans congratulations we now have
socialist comrade Elizabeth Warren I
don't and I'll tell you why one like you
I believe in the Constitution in the
system and when I was a kid my father
said you know and I remember the exact
words a basically real strength real
conviction is that when something
doesn't benefit you is it the right
thing you know in other words we're
anything so the Constitution is my guide
and the fact that we can have this
debate and the ability to correct in
this country we have a cultural DNA in
the Declaration of Independence we have
a legal DNA in the Constitution and the
Bill of Rights and we
the Federalist Papers and other things
but what it frames is this idea that the
country can self correct the Supreme
Court can make a decision the other
branches can get involved with their
respective roles and we can correct
things we've fixed things in this
country and it's difficult and it should
be we don't want easy flip-flops so I
don't fear a Libertarian Party that's
strong I want it because I think can
help the other parties self-correct you
know more strength more voices not less
more strength to me is better a strong
nation is less challenged by outsiders
what I want a weak nation well I want a
stronger nation and I we can weather the
challenges yeah as far as for the
Socialists we do have an issue here in
this country and I think there is a
level of ignorance willful ignorance and
ideology combined that's dangerous
anything is when it magnifies enough and
it gets a loud voice and it's used and
abused by many out there who actually
don't even know the difference that's a
danger because what it does is it robs
people of that the part of their life
especially when you're younger when you
should be building towards your future
and once you've lost a chunk of that how
do you get it back that's a danger yeah
so what do we do to change the factory
settings of how people are brought up
it's a it's a phrase that my friend
Bridget fed as he came up with tennis
who I think it's really perfect that
basically the factory settings if you
grow up in America are all sort of lefty
or democratic factory settings you know
we should take from some and give to the
other the government is somehow
inherently good while all of these pot
the policies of the Democrats are just
like the thing that you're just sort of
basically taught and then you go from
there where in my view the factory
settings we should all get would
actually be very libertarian it would be
all about freedom and individual rights
and individual liberty and then you
figure out well where do we actually
need government and that's why I can
still consider myself a classical
liberal or not a libertarian because I
do believe there is some utility for the
state it's just it's just real politics
like I want to jump in yeah
we would normally so what I would prefer
is if education would get everybody to
the point of understand the Constitution
understand the documents you just laid
out so that we are free first right then
let's have the argument about when we
when we need government but we do it the
other way we do it that the government
is inherently good they gave you all the
rights they're supposed to give you this
stuff and free this free that man and
then occasionally somebody on the right
can come in and maybe move that down a
little bit but it seems to me that we're
doing this thing upside down decades of
building a political system that's based
on a career not service building a
support system in a bureaucracy and call
it a large interest whatever that
interest may be that supports the
bureaucracy we have a system that more
resembles a dinosaur in too many ways
which is a small brain a huge animal and
inefficient system and one that doesn't
recognize its receive the deathblow on
one end of the body because the brain is
not equipped for it and that's what I
see and where we are now
the self-correct on this I think is more
evident in parts of the country that
don't get the attention Lyman Wyoming
Cheyenne somewhere out in Paxton
Nebraska in other areas where people
don't wake up every day and see things
the way you and I do they'll check the
Twitter and the president don't checks
Sanders wire you know they didn't live
in this those are the people we have to
engage I still believe and I see it
anecdotally and I think it's supported
by a lot of the studies that there are
more people in this country that if
they're engaged are that silent majority
now whether they're right or left I
think they fall more in the American
cultural value system they don't fear
freedom but maybe they don't understand
fully the risk and reward that comes
with freedom there's there's a risk yeah
there there's risk when what you're
describing happens when we go upside
down when it comes to freedom we've got
to realize that it's inherent risk and
reward is why it works
and I think there are more of those
people out there that are coming to that
Center the problem is they haven't been
engaged properly by either party and
they need to be brought into it what do
we do then to make more let's say
inclusive right this is this is one of
the interesting things that I find right
now most of my audience is it's a little
hard to say but I would say it's
something like half of my own answers
probably former lefties and a huge
percentage of those people they're still
like ah those people on the right like I
mean think the less nuts but those
people on the right are really they're
everybody's nuts Hussein right
everybody's nuts who's saying but that's
what I'm trying to show them in that
it's not the case because what I have
consistently seen is that the right
while not being perfect and nothing is
something like gay marriage for example
the right now has basically well nobody
talks about gay marriage anymore
nobody's fighting for gay marriage to be
reversed there is literally nobody doing
it the voices in the Republican Party
that we're rapidly against it saying
Mike Huckabee and Rick Santorum really
have no power in the Republican Party
anymore so I've seen an ability to to be
flexible intellectually on the right
what is it that you guys can do to
further that if you think that that's a
good thing to do well no I think it is a
good thing to do to evolve again I trust
the Constitution the people to make as a
whole the better choice not pure
democracy not mob rule but to make a
better choice based on some things that
they do control in some things they
don't control back in the 80s if you had
a black friend you were cool by the mid
to late 80s if you had a gay friend no
you were really cool that both you were
like man I'm hanging in the club at a
time exactly but there's a truth there
because what happened Generation started
to evolve those people who were cool
suddenly saw people differently you know
like how teammates each other I know you
may come from that side and that side
but we're playing on the same team which
is the American team so as the
generation evolves the parties didn't
always evolve
the Republican Party failed to engage
blacks and urban neighborhoods because
they had a strategy from 85 with the
evangelicals I get it reality a
political party right red state blue
state Republican Democrat county carve
them up you get your wins I get mine we
play we redistricted so the party's
failed but the culture is evolving and
the party has to come along eventually
problem is the party takes longer to
come along I don't have to agree with
someone and that's not required neither
is my offense or someone else's offense
necessary because it's about freedom and
I think the people will drag it along
which is why I still hold more faith in
the Millennials then people on the right
or left do are there ones that are
troublesome yes but are there more of
them in this country what do you do as I
do it I've been every state and I've
talked to people and I see more people
who are saying just let me live let me
do what I can do to get my life where it
is and stop trying to sell me on what I
need to believe if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell